[Music]
so
[Music]
hello my name is cecil slipovic and i'm
musician in residence at yale
university's
fortune of video archive for holocaust
testimonies
this video series is designed as a
companion to our album
where is our homeland which is the first
volume in the archives ongoing effort
to present songs and poems performed by
survivors in testimonies given to the
fortune of archive
over the last 40 years you can learn
more about the project on the archives
website
songs from testimonies.org
where is our homeland songs from
testimonies volume 1
was recorded in 2019 by the cecil
slupovich ensemble
featuring renowned singer sasha luria
craig udelman on the violin joshua camp
on the accordion
keyboards and guitar dmitry ischenko on
the base
and myself on woodwinds the songs in
this collection differ vastly in terms
of style
social and historical background
language and many other aspects
but collectively they create a
multi-dimensional picture
of jewish life before and during world
war
ii jack m
was one of the wonderful folk singers he
had a tremendous memory
and he remembered a lot of the pre-war
repertoire
coming from the weddings from his home
from the army from the street from the
school
and his testimony not only reveals his
personal experience
during the holocaust but it really gives
us a
really deep insight into
what jewish polish culture was before
the war
one of the songs that jack sang on the
testimony
is bothen song the bothen was a wedding
jester
a figure that was really instrumental in
the
ashkenazic jewish wedding beginning
1400s
and through the 20th century
uh as a boy jack remembered two bahanim
uh which is a plural of abathan uh
in his small town of chidwaviats
one was a hasidic religious person the
other was
more of a secular badgen
and um that song
was arranged uh by us by this east of
sapovich ensemble and performed
on the album where is our homeland um
with the wonderful soloist singer sasha
luria
so we decided to open it with the doina
which is a semi-improvisatory
instrumental composition uh this
particular doina
came from the collection of moise
baragowski a notable ukrainian jewish
soviet ethnographer who captured along
with sophia magid
another musicologist from leningrad
saint petersburg
uh the last moments of the
old world pre-war jewish tradition
in belarus and ukraine
so although jack came from poland but
opening the composition with adona makes
it
really a lifelike music making situation
the song is followed by the frelox tune
the mocking street song
was mr quetzal barroygus why are you so
angry
honey
the biggest kick of inner wedding was
the majority and marshalling
was out of this world he was the
entertainer
he was the announcer of the russian they
didn't give no money just presents which
day
we got to entertain them in that first
we had two one was a a religious guy
and the other one was shahad weltik
worldly non-religious or worldly yeah
yeah the religious guy he
made it in hasidic he gave them
no
[Music]
[Music]
be
[Music]
[Applause]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
m
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Applause]
the song of the martial lake the badgen
which is described as the biggest kick
in a wedding
what's the context what's what's going
on here
well it's it's a wedding and
we know a wedding has a groom and a
bride and the family
and the officiator
maybe a rabbi
friends maybe
some poor people are being invited as
well
depending on how wealthy the family is
and there's one person who kind of uh
provides the glue the continuity
uh and that's the marshallik the bodhin
and the role of the bodhin or the
martial luke as
jack m remembers him is to
both entertain and also instruct
and keep things moving
so there are
two of these martial licks that uh that
jack remembers from his
uh growing up in pre-war eastern europe
one of them was a religious guy who was
a a husted and did things
sort of by the book straight
and the other one he describes as shahad
spathik
that means it was already a heartache
and uh that probably means that
his parents were caused a lot of
heartache by his
strain from the path of religious
observance
but on the other hand it gave him that
point of view that made him a good
entertainer
because he took things with a grain of
salt and he knew how to make
clever double entendres and jokes
and it was very entertaining to the
point that jack
remembers him as providing the biggest
kick in a wedding
so in today's weddings i think
we would uh place this somewhere
in the area of a toast to the couple
which sometimes turns into a roast
because
the family and friends who are
celebrating
the marriage with the uh
man and wife to be or wife and wife or
man and man
are often making little inside jokes and
referring to
old nicknames that are a little
embarrassing but not too embarrassing
and that's the spirit of of the
matalic who is trying to
lighten the mood and also keep things
real and
not leave it only at the religious
precepts
that his job is also partly to
impart to the couple so
here we have aman shalik who is
addressing
only the male members of the wedding
party this is before
the groom is taken to meet the bride
and proceed with the ceremony so this is
all men this is the the
groom and his father principally
and the other members of the male
members of the community
and the martial that begins by saying
that's the groom his dad
says
don't try to be a wise guy don't try to
be play the fool
don't pretend that you don't understand
what's going on
that's what his dad is saying and then
the martial continues
listen to what your old man is saying
is
and your anger at me
contain it you know just
hold yourself back here don't be angry
with me i'm just the messenger
very interesting why is the groom
angry what's the anger about
cass the the anger is that
the groom is about to lose his
independence you're no longer going to
be
a free single
young person with no responsibilities
and no he's going to have to become a
full-fledged member of the community
take on all the obligations of marriage
and it's a scary transition
as one he apparently
doesn't want to take on he's angry about
it
so the the martial look continues to
explain
you can't sleep you can't eat he can't
sleep he's so agitated
this formulation is one that we find in
another context of romantic songs a love
song
where uh for example in
holland we hear
[Music]
i can't eat i can't sleep i'm not eating
sleeping i'm not sleeping through the
night
i can't eat i can't drink because i'm
longing for you my love
uh my sweetheart
this is a different kind of not being
able to eat or sleep
it's being upset and anxious at the
transition about to happen
and what's causing the anxiety
[Applause]
because it's written
it's written in the torah in the sacred
law
so says our creator
a jew must not remain alone
must not be alone
[Music]
a wife he has to take he has to have a
wife
and now comes the punchline
[Music]
who will be able the wife right will be
able later to bury
him
a jew must not be alone
so that's the precept and
this uh this sort of double entendre
solemn ken and shbetter
literally means will later be able to
bury him which is a bit like
uh getting married and having children
so that you will have
a kadhisho you will have
someone who can say kaddish after you
yes if you get married then
when you die your partner will be able
to make sure that you are brought to
cavity scale that you were buried
according to jewish law
but also also it means
uh to vanquish if you
if you bury someone it's like on the
battlefield here it's the battle of the
sexes
where you bury someone it means that you
vanquish them you conquer them so
it's a kind of wisdom
and wisecrack rolled into one
a piece of wisdom but also a wise crack
and this is this is the way of the
martial
who is entertaining but also
fulfilling his obligation to lay down
the law
and make sure that the participants of
the wedding
understand what's uh what's in store for
them and
and what they're getting into
we have uh in the literature for example
izukmanga
uh writes about the badhran who is
in in that case addressing the bride and
this is another convention
of explaining how
sad this day is for the bride because
like the groom who's about to lose his
independence the bride is about to lose
her beauty so we have for example
in that song uh that i'm thinking of
from [ __ ]
um
life is a shadow
[Music]
beauty fades like the setting sun
on corn it's sorry
[Music]
with tears in his eyes so in that case
it's manga is painting a little
portrait of a different moment in the
ritual where the botgun
is addressing the bride in
the martial look song that that jack m
remembers from growing up it's the
martial lake having a little fun with
reminding the groom
i yiddle it thoroughness i know lane
you know you got to get married because
a jew cannot be alone
[Music]
you